fernand le déroulé de ce cette réunion
informelle porte sur le premier point
qui nous a mobilisés
en john bost sur la boussole stratégique
ce document qui est je vais d'hier le
premier véritable livre blanc la défense
européenne et qui sera un élément
essentiel de l'affirmation de la
souveraineté européenne
sujet sur lequel la présidence française
veut pouvoir aboutir au cours de cette
présidence est singulièrement si
possible au conseil
de du mois de mars
et je crois que cet échange a été majeur
et a permis de fixer les priorités pour
la politique de sécurité de défense
jusqu'à l'horizon 2030
et je tenais pas parlé mais j'ai eu ce
ce drôle de sentiment
que nous étions déjà en application de
la boussole stratégiques au cours de
cette réunion informelle avant même
qu'elles ne soient mises en oeuvre
puissent qu'ils étaient 11 ans a été
amené depuis hier après midi à engager
des discussions sur les sujets sont trop
concernant notre sécurité tout se
passait comme si on avait déjà anticipé
la boussole stratégique va dire que sur
les questions liées à la russie à
l'ukraine ce qui m'a frappé le plus
c'est gelé dit
hier
soir
c'est la détermination et l'unité
de l'ensemble de nos collègues
la réaffirmation d'une posture
dissuasive ferme
vis-à-vis de toutes nouvelles atteintes
éventuelles à l'intégrité territoriale
de l'ukraine
et
le haut représentant rappelé tout à
l'heure les les 10 points
pour appeler ça le décalogue de borel 10
points le décalogue de postes en tout
cas cette posture dissuasive ferme en
application d'ailleurs des engagements
qui avaient été pris au moment du
conseil européen du 16 décembre toute
nouvelle agression militaire contre
l'ukraine aurait des conséquences
massive et un coup sévère en réponse
cela a été réaffirmé de manière
extrêmement forte et extrêmement
solidaire
j'ai noté aussi cette convergence
sur l'importance de poursuivre un un
dialogue exigeant avec la russie notre
volonté de le faire sous réserve que les
paramètres de discussion soit partagée
et qu' il ne se fasse pas sur la forme
d'un ultimatum et mais nous nous
souhaitons que le plus haut d'engagement
le plus aux angles niveau d'engagement
européen possible soit effectué dans les
différentes enceintes du dialogue que ce
soit l'enceinte du format normandie
où la france est et l'allemagne vont
poursuivre leurs efforts pour obtenir
des gestes de retour vers la mise en
oeuvre des accords de minsk
annales et la barbe hoc et et moi même
nous sommes entretenu de ce sujet et
nous ferons une visite commune
en ukraine dans les jours qui viennent
dames 1 banque va se rendre en ukraine
parce que c'est son premier déplacement
je crois lundi et elle va préparer un
déplacement commun de l'allemagne et de
la france sur la frontière de si la
ligne de sécurité ligne de démarcation
et et à kiev dans ce cadre là nous nous
souhaitons bien réaffirmer
la position européenne que le
représentant a pu réaffirmer lors de son
déplacement récent en ukraine nous
voulons le réaffirmer aussi dans le
cadre de la discussion
russo américaines sur la maîtrise des
armements nucléaires stratégiques la
suite de enfin la suite de new start
l'appréciation de la mise en oeuvre de
nos stats aujourd'hui nous le faisons en
coordination très étroite avec notre
allié américain
nous souhaitons affirmer notre présence
forte à l'otan où nous avons été très
actif dans la préparation du conseil
otan russie et nous souhaitons aussi que
sur ce sujet la discussion sur la
maîtrise des armements nucléaires
intermédiaires et conventionnelles
puisse se poursuivre nous sommes nés
exprimé sur ce sujet et puis pour suivre
aussi à l'eau et c'est eux ou des
discussions commencées sur la maîtrise
des armements conventionnels et sur les
grands principes de l'asl architecture
de sécurité européenne et l'union
européenne s'y est exprimé d'une seule
voix et puis ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure
josep borrell était très important sur
la coordination
nous allons renforcer notre coordination
pour eux être cohérent dans l'ensemble
des formats sur lesquels nous avons à
nous exprimer et faire en sorte que
cette coordination puisse apporter la
présence forte de l'union européenne et
l'unité delà des positions européennes
qui ont été actés au cours de cette
réunion informelle nous le ferons
évidemment en relation très étroite avec
le secrétaire d'état blinken on va dire
deux mots sur eux
sur
le mali puis que nous avons en traiter
cette question tout à l'heure je sais
peu pour elle a rappelé notre position
nous avons apprécié
la posture courageuse ferme de la cedeao
lors de sa réunion d'une dimanche
dernier
prise à l unanimité
avec la volonté de préserver la
démocratie
au mali avec aussi le la condamnation de
présent si tu développement de la
société de mercenaires wagner
et comme l'a dit josette borel nous
sommes
déterminés à soutenir la cedeao dans
l'appui à ces démarches et la mise en
oeuvre des mesures qui ont été décidées
à la fois dans le gel des appuis
budgétaires qu'ils soient européens ou
qu'ils soient nationaux puisque lors ce
qui concerne la france ça sera le cas à
condition que ça ne porte pas atteinte à
à la population et donc les opérations
liées au développement seront maintenus
est ce qu a dit josette tout de suite je
le partage nous sommes et nous voulons
rester au mali mais pas à n'importe quel
prix et nous sommes au mali pour
combattre le terrorisme et pas pour
autre chose nous nous continuons à
suivre la situation de très près et nous
allons réunir après la rencontre des
ministres des affaires étrangères du g5
sahel que va initier le représentant
nous allons réunir la coalition
la coalition internationale pour le
sahel
il ya soixante mans dans cette coalition
beau des états européens et africains
des états unis d'autres
et plusieurs organisations
internationales pour faire le point de
la situation après les décisions prises
par la cedeao à la suite de la volonté
de la junte de ne pas mener la
transition dans les délais qu'elle avait
initialement prévu un mot sur les l'état
des discussions sur le nucléaire iranien
parce que nous avons abordé cette
question j'ai eu l'occasion il ya
quelques jours de déclarer que cette
négociation qui a repris
après cinq mois d'interruption
et après
une situation de blocage encore aux
avant la fin de l'année dernière elle a
repris plus tôt mieux au début de
l'année mais cette négociation avance
beaucoup trop lentement et chacun est
conscient que le choix aujourd'hui n'est
pas de conclure dans quelques semaines
dans quelques mois mais le choix il est
de choisir entre un accord de retour au
jeu s'appellera très rapide où une crise
de prolifération relancer avec l'iran
donc il importe que nous puissions
accéléré parce que cette négociation se
trouve devant une forme d'urgence vitale
il faut maintenant aboutir et tranchées
ou bien les iraniens veulent conclure et
alors le sentiment que la flexibilité et
l'agilité de la posture américaine pour
être au rendez vous il ne veut pas
conclure et à son homologue sommes
devant une crise majeure de
prolifération en tout cas nous avons
souhaité et les uns et les autres qu'il
y ait une vraie accélération je précise
d'ailleurs à cet égard que
l'enjeu iranien c'est un véritable enjeu
européen à la fois par la géographie ici
la proximité les risques ça représente
les menaces qui sont plutôt sur nos
territoires à la fois historique est ce
que ce sont les européens qui depuis
2003 ont été à l'initiative du processus
de négociation pour éviter la
prolifération nucléaire et à la fois
pratique puisque c'est le haut
représentant qui assure la coordination
du travail du
groupe qui réunit à la fois les trois
européens les états unis qui n'y sont
plus mais la chine la russie et l'iran
évidemment le cette coordination est
européenne elle doit se poursuivre mais
aujourd'hui c'est un signal d' alerte ça
va beaucoup trop lentement pour pouvoir
aboutir un résultat parce que si ça se
poursuit ainsi il n'y aura plus rien à
négocier puisque l'avancé des iraniens
dans le
vers la production de matières fissiles
se poursuit et un moment donné il ne
sera plus nécessaire de négocier
puisqu'il n'y aura plus rien à discuter
enfin nous avons une réunion extrêmement
importante avec
le président moussa faki et madame à
aïssata tall sall il les affaires
étrangères du sénégal le sénégal
président
l'union africaine à partir du 5 février
prochain pour préparer le sommet ua qui
se tiendra les 17 et 18 février
prochains à bruxelles c'est un sommet
stratégique ça se réunit de tous les
trois ans et non chacun a souhaité que
ce soit le début d'une nouvelle donne
entre l'afrique et l'europe entre
l'union africaine et l'union européenne
autour de deux thèmes de la prospérité
de la sécurité et de la mobilité
partagée sous forme de new deal européen
qui a pour objectif de renforcer la
souveraineté des états africains qui est
aussi un élément important de la
souveraineté européenne
il n'évite ablement nous serons amenés à
parler aussi dans ce sommet du mois de
février des enjeux de santé de la lutte
contre le coc vie de 19 en particulier
en afrique mais on sera aussi amené à
évoquer l'ensemble de l'architecturé
euro-africaine de sécurité sans doute
pour essayer de rebâtir un dispositif
qui soit plus sécurisant et plus
performant en articulation et en
partenariat avec nos collègues africains
je m'arrête là monsieur le représentant
parce qu'autrement on va prendre trop de
temps oui
j'ai dû me permets jean niv je
n'ajouterai rien
dans son rapport sur le la rencontrerez
des africa parce que tu es at il dit
c'était une rencontre
le prochain sommet rencontre le
fondamental
on a bien préparé aujourd'hui dans un
dialogue franc qu il faut il faut bien
mettre en avant ce que les problèmes de
l'afrique ce sont les problèmes de
l'europe nous partageons le même
problème c'est pas que nous nous allons
résoudre ou aider à résoudre le problème
des africains ces problèmes les
problèmes de l'afrique ce sont les
problèmes de l'europe parfois c'est le
revers de la médaille de c'est la même
chose
se soit sécurité terrorisme changement
climatique migration
ce problème sur nos problèmes le conseil
aussi à traiter sur la chine faudrait
pas passer outre de ça on a discuté sur
la chine
deux points de vue nos rapports
bilatéraux et le rôle de la sinne et
l'influent chinoises dans les
organisations internationales
ne pas y avoir aussi un sommet union
européenne chine a priori ça pue y
aurait cependant à la fin du mois de
mars ce qui va offrir l'opportunité de
voyager en russie pour préparer ce
sommet c'est ça sera aussi un sommet
important pour passer une entrevue
prévoir où ce que nous en sommes dans le
rapport avec la chine il ya des choses
qui vont bien d'autres niveaux moins de
biens en particulier les conseils à
discuter les actions chinoises contre la
lituanie et les effets secondaires que
ses actions sur d'autres états membres
sur le marché intérieur européen
mais évidemment mon esprit c'est se
priver toute sa solidarité vers la
lituanie et ils ont discuté de quelle
façon on pourrait activement poursuivre
la discussion
c'est pas comme sont bien français la
dsca jusqu'à lundi salade dans dance est
dans cette église
on a passé en revue leurs au déni au
global au maine initiative de la chine
qui réflexe la fois la volonté chinoise
de se projeter dans le monde et de
besoin de rester vigilant pour savoir de
quelle manière ça touche nos intérêts et
le rôle aussi dans le monde
sur l'iran
tu as tout à fait raison janiw je pense
qu'on arrive à la fin d'un long
processus qui
même si j'en parle pas tous les jours me
tient très occupés moi et mes
collaborateurs
sont à vienne pl activement il habite à
vienne depuis quelques mois mais
l'ambiance meilleur après noël
avant noël j'étais très pessimiste
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y avait une
possibilité d'arriver à un accord je
pense qu'il ya une possibilité
c'est vrai qu'il faut accélérer parce
qu'on me l'a dit le ministre l'étudiant
sur yron devient une puissance nucléaire
n'y aura plus rien et aussi parce que le
but de la corse était éviter ça il faut
surfer quand même rappeler que l'accord
marché bien jusqu'au moment où les plus
en jambes a décidé de quitter
et donc il faut essayer de faire revenir
à nouveau de ces états unis à l'accord
et que les iraniens reviennent aussi à
l'accomplissement des lagons
et ça c'est un travail
très important et dans les prochaines
semaines
j'espère avoir l'occasion de vous
informer sur le résultat final je
maintiens encore l'espoir que ça sera
possible de re-faire l'accord le faire
fonctionner qu on veut fonctionner avant
le
arrêtez les américains
mais
pour compléter ses hôtes pour le
compléter sur l'iran parce que ce n'est
pas le sujet de départ mais il n'y a
plus rien à négocier si rien ne se passe
ni pour éviter l'accession de l'iran au
nucléaire mais ni parallèlement pour
l'iran de bénéficier de la levée des
sanctions ça veut dire les deux choses
je dis là pour les iraniens c'est ça
veut dire que si j a pas d'accélération
n'ya pas non plus de levée de sanction
donc face à la salle je prends
le monsieur
est ce que vous pouvez nous préciser un
petit peu ce que concrètement veulent
dire les des contre-propositions les
positions européennes
dont vous avez discuté que vous avez
esquissé dans le dialogue entre les
russes et les américains avec les russes
et les américains d'une part et d'autre
part ce matin en arrivant la ministre
suédoise a dit qu'elle est la suède
allait suspendre participation sa
participation à la force takouba ainsi
qu'à la mission de formation european
homes au mali
est-ce que vous avez noté d'autres
désistement de la santé et qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça comme conséquence par
rapport à l'engagement européen il n'y a
pas de désistement de la suède
c'est une illusion d'optique
dans la mesure où il y à un certain
nombre de pays qui se sont engagés dans
l'opération takouba
dizaines et lorsqu'il s'engagea
l'opération takouba ses pays membres
dont la suède dit moi je ferais
l'opération takouba de telle date
at-elle d'âne avec temps d'effectifs or
ce qu'a dit la ministre elle est venue
me le dire parce qu'elle n'était pas
d'accord avec la manière dont une des
tâches d'âge ans avait été rédigé ou
interpréter peu importe on arrêt à la
fin de l'année c'est la fin du
contingent de takouba suédois et on va
passer 1
jean d'un autre un autre pays membre on
n'y a pas de départ il ya simplement de
l'application des engagements pris par
la suède à l'égard de la communauté
internationale donc il faut laisser les
choses là où elles sont et non pas
ailleurs
concernant les engagements pour
aider la position de par ailleurs qu'a
rappelé josette borel c'est nous sommes
aux
lignes nous y restons on rajoute pas
dans n'importe quelle condition et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous allons nous
retrouver
dans la conférence de la coalition que
nous allons organiser dans quelques
jours à bruxelles
sur les
les contre-propositions je pense que le
décalogue qui a été évoqué il ya un
instant part au représentant
représentent des contre-propositions et
son connaissez pas de nouvelles
contre-proposition les votre opposition
c'est revenir aux grands principes de
l'acte final d'helsinki et de la charte
de paris de 90 qui proclame
l'inviolabilité des frontières qui
indique que chaque état doit s'abstenir
de toute menace ou utilisation de la
force contre un autre état en europe qui
est dit que les droits humains et les
libertés fondamentales doivent être
respectés que chaque état est libre
d'appartenir à telle ou telle
organisation internationale ce sont les
éléments de
deux des actes de l'acte final
d'helsinki de la charte de paris validée
en 1975 par eux par l'urss ça c'est pour
les grands principes dont cocetta en
particulier au sein de l'eau et ce que
nous voulons poursuivre ses propositions
dans le dialogue otan russie nous nous
souhaitons qu'ils puissent être mises en
oeuvre les paramètres d'un nouvel
instrument qui permettrait de gérer la
parte la suite de du traité est fini
qu'il n'existe plus qui est caduc et
peut-être d'autres mais aussi peut-être
de se mettre d'accord par ailleurs par
ailleurs sur la transparence sur les
opérations militaires conventionnelles
et en particulier sur les manoeuvres
militaires conventionnelles et puis à
l'eau et c'est peut-être faire en sorte
de moderniser le document de vienne qui
vise à renforcer la prévisibilité
activités militaires et de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait une plus grande
transparence nous avons mis tout ça sur
la table on va leur mettre ce que vient
de dire le haut représentant
conforte cette cette position après il
faut les instances pour en parler elles
ont été définis on les connaît et
évidemment le signe l'ukrainien sera à
cet égard un signe tout à fait essentiel
de la part de la russie
question
d'un journaliste connectés par zoom
alors nous allons prendre
merci s'il vous plaît de vous présenter
de présenter votre métier avant de poser
la question
oui
le journal suisse
monsieur le même problème en serait
le gouvernement lituanien
n'est pas qualifié
en lettonie de rétractation comme le
fait de ne pas y paie comme c'est avec
tout le monde y compris
merci bien
j'ai pas compris
sur la lituanie et la chine parce que
vous considérez
sur la lituanie et la chine
vont exprimer aujourd'hui et ce n'était
pas la première fois notre totale
solidarité avec la lituanie
et la condamnation des actes de
coercition menée par la chine
comme vous le savez il y ait un
dispositif anti coercition qui a été
mise sur la table par la commission il
ya peu de temps et une forme de nos
réponses ce sera d'aboutir à ce que sous
présidence française il ya une
accélération du ce texte pour permettre
de réagir aussi à l'égard des mesures
d'intimidation et de coercition que mène
la chine à l'égard de la lituanie pays
avec lequel nous sommes totalement
solidaires
prochaine question j'ai encore une
question nicolas d'abord
bonjour monsieur le représentant
monsieur le ministre je pense que vous
avez répondu déjà sur la chine par
avance je voulais savoir j'avais une
interrogation par rapport à la
cyberattaque ukrainienne est ce que j'ai
bien compris que vous pouviez la tribu
et de façon claire ou moins claires à un
acteur qui pourrait être un acteur russe
gouvernementales ou non gouvernementales
donc je voulais savoir si vous pouviez
précisé cet aspect et pour le ministre
jean yves le drian je voulais savoir sur
le mali vous étiez ministre de la
défense moment de l'envoi des forces
françaises je pense si mes souvenirs
sont bons est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
vous avez déjà expliqué en long large on
va pas revenir dessus mais est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas déçu un petit peu est ce
que vous regrettez pas cet engagement
d'être venu au secours des maggie est ce
que vous n'êtes pas un peu amer de voir
comment gérer la situation a tourné
merci beaucoup
c'est dans la tête que suivre un éthique
d'une certaine ampleur
à certaines
options de la ministre jordanienne
commençons par le siège de la présidence
honnêtement ce n'est pas de preuve
qu'une pause mais permettre de signaler
avec la force de l'évidence à quelqu'un
passe encore vous savez les attaques
cybernétiques
parfois c'est difficile de savoir qui de
sa fait on arrive à savoir ne pas tout
de suite et vous moi je prépare
je peux pas passer au delà de la logique
pour entrer dans l'évidence donc je ne
peux pas pointer à personne mais peut
très bien imaginer
les improbabilités
ou et marge d'erreur nous a fait
parvenir
en tout cas l'important c'est que
l'ukraine c'est qu'elle compte avec une
haute head
ce matin nous avons décidé mettre à sa
disposition
des équipes de spécialistes un cyber
défense
pour qu'il les aide à faire face à des
événements comme celui-ci que j'ai
craint fort malheureusement ce ne sera
pas le dernier donc maintenant offerts
on est prêt à envoyer dès que nous le
demandent les spécialistes de nos jeux
rapides seiver gloups
nous le savons
nous avons un projet baisse coquilles
justement tête de comment faire face aux
salves de la taxe le cren pas ses
membres de l'union européenne dont ça
fait pas partie non plus de ces projets
mais les états membres concernés sont
prêts à déployer les moyens pour revenir
à l'est de l'ukraine où six personnes à
l'année
dans cette perspective là là je ne parle
pas comme
président de
la conférence mais comme me disent
français la france est tout à fait
disposé par l'onuci a contribué à cette
mission technique que si elle est
demandée par les ukrainiens
moi j'ai souvenir
de janvier 2013
j'ai souvenir
de la fin d'après midi du jour on a
déclenché les opérations de la mort de
damien boiteux
premier mort français morts pour
que le mali vivre libres
et j'ai aussi toujours
en présence
le monument aux morts que j'ai initiées
dans les jardins de l'ambassade de
france à bamako
en mémoire
à tous les soldats français qui sont
morts pour la liberté du mali
malheureusement
après que j'ai quitté le ministre de la
défense ont ils fait encore eu d'audit
et non à s'ajouter
nous avons combattu pour la liberté des
maliens et nous sommes toujours là pour
combattre les terroristes
qui veulent porter atteinte à cette
liberté et si nous n'étions pas
intervenus au mois de janvier 2013 alors
ce pays serait devenu un état islamique
comme
le projet en était de dèche à jaca
et cette intervention
a permis d'une part d'éviter ça et
d'autre part de mettre en oeuvre un
processus démocratique
puisque des deux maîtresses il ya eu des
élections présidentielle et des
élections législatives qui se sont
retrouvés après
donc
ce qui ne s'est pas passé après c'est la
mise en oeuvre des accords d'alger la
volonté politique de l'admettre en neuf
ans
mais les accords d'alger sont toujours
là
ils avaient la volonté politique n'est
toujours pas là
hélas la prise de position de la cédéao
est une peau de prises de positions non
seulement courageuse mais aussi qui fait
référence à l'histoire et à la propre
sécurité des pays africains de l'afrique
de l'ouest c'est la raison pour laquelle
joseph bourrel le rap est tout à l'heure
il ya eu unanimité des nos collègues
pour appuyer la démarche de la céder
roues c'est une démarche d'initiative
africaine
je me permets une dernière observation
puisqu'il y a aujourd'hui des
manifestations à bamako
et puisque là la raison qui est invoquée
par la junte
d'allonger la transition
jusque durée de cinq ans la raison qui
est invoqué des raisons de sécurité et
on ne peut pas procéder à des votes
parce que nous sommes pas en sécurité
je pense que si on est en sécurité pour
manifester on doit sûrement être en
sécurité pour voter
merci je reprends une question en salle
alors le monsieur derrière après toi
fils allez-y
bonjour et métayers le télégramme
monsieur le représentant monsieur le
ministre est ce que vous seriez d'accord
pour dire qu'il ya eu au jeu au sortir
de ces réunions
rapprochement des positions des 27 sur
les questions de sécurité ces positions
étaient précédemment assez divergentes
est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya eu un
rapprochement une prise de conscience
commune
à la faveur si je veux dire de la crise
en ukraine de dépositions de sécurité
des vingt-sept merci
certainement certaines immenses il
arrive souvent quand on discute un
abstrait on se permet plus de diversion
c'est quand on fait face à un problème
concret vous avez mélasse certes à vos
portes oui je m'en réjouis je me réjouis
dès que aujourd'hui ayant sentiment
d'appartenance
beaucoup plus profond que l'habitude une
approche de point de vue
on
saute
on un détail peut
pas tuer
la volonté de faire marche arrière
pâques est il
[Musique]
que confirmer ce que des représentants
des caisses
l'hippodrome informel
ne font de solidarité femmes ne
il volonté
l'eau
leçon que nous
sommes
facilement que ça fait dix ans que je
fais
le soir ce soir pour vous deux
vous demander si vous estimez que le
syntaxe du monsieur le ministre le
décalogue de brevets
déposés
est-ce que c'est qu'il fait pourtant de
prendre une année chez telus européen
format
messalistes eu lieu à moscou album seule
chose que j'ai réellement merkel est dit
en macro l'avait assassiné
[Musique]
à nouveau sommet
avec le kremlin
on discute pas et
un pistolet sous la dent pourrie d'un
modèle dire tant
les positions sont pas des positions
la déclinaison
représentants
à manifester dans ses rangs dans la
chaude les
jeunes que nous fassions enfants
mais surtout
sur la base
de l'autre côté
ces trois éléments
les moyens
supplémentaires à l'intégrité de
l'ukraine est très très clair et très
largement partagée et très vigoureuse en
même temps nous avons toujours dit il
faut aussi trouver le schéma du dial je
maintiens que nous avons les bases
communes pour le faire après de quelle
manière cela peut se faire pour laisser
le temps
ouvrir les opportunités
je voudrais pas que ça s'appelle décider
pour elles de se faire le disque blesse
je suis d'accord le dise de brest la
salle de presse mais cela reste et moi
je vais passer les caravaniers que ça
reste le décalogue de brest si vous
voulez ce n'est rien d'extraordinaire à
l'exceptionnelle maps et on vient pas de
découvrir la roue mais je pense que
c'est bien des groupes et dans de
nombreux jeunes hommes qu'on est habitué
à utiliser l'e10
l'ensemble des éléments que nous croyons
qu'il faut
avoir un tête quand on fait face au
problème de la sécurité noble et j'ai
toujours cru qu'avec la russie font
dialoguer j'ai essayé de le faire
et va continuer à le faire
et bien sûr le président m'a plomb et la
chancelière ex chancelière merkel ont
été aussi en faveur
dialogue tu penses que c'est pas
contradictoire la ferme était avec les
dialogues faut être fermes dans la
défense de ses intérêts ses positions
même temps il faut être ouvert à un
dialogue parce que ce la seule façon
d'un pc les tensions
et en ce moment on va pratiquer si
possible ses dialogues
tout en étant quand je dis ferme dans
nos positions des deux supports à
l'ukraine et notre volonté de défendre
des principes qui nous paraissent
impossible de renoncer on ne peut pas
faire marche arrière à l'histoire
c'est à dire
coupé réinventer préparer abondé le
scénario tient aux politiques qui a été
dépassé de l'existence même de l'union
européenne
et ça c'est une occasion aussi pour
l'union européenne exister politiquement
tu sais que tu as eu beaucoup de
critiques des âmes l'union européenne
n'est pas assise à la table
évidemment non n'attendez pas y être a
pas demandé d'y être c'est la russie
demande de parler avec les états unis
avec le temps par là que les états unis
avec le temps mais aussi bien les
etats-unis que l'otan clairement en tête
que s'il s'agit de parler de la sécurité
des surcoûts perles de quoi on parle
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut être
agréable ne seront peints et si les
négociations devaient continuer ce qu'
ils paraissent opalka soyeux sur les
européens auraient emmené par c'est
inconcevable que ça ne soit pas comme ça
et je dois dire que je répète que
jusqu'à maintenant je suis très
satisfait de l'attitude de ces états
unis
et du secrétaire général de l'otan
c'est évident que la russie a essayé de
nous diviser un passant par le sud le
nord européen comme si nous n'existions
pas
en nous ignorant de la essayer de le
diviser et montrer une figure de la
presse samedi à bâle
l'europe n'est pas là on divise le monde
libre
mais les états unis n'ont pas joué le
jeu au contraire dès le premier moment
ils nous ont assuré que rien ne serez
pas discuté ni décider sur l'europe sans
je répète le mot et serviteurs des
tables inc sans être en coordination
luis
un participation of du de vince
est certainement ça a été comme ça et je
réussis de coûts d'appels des blinken
demain je vais avoir une autre beaucoup
de mes collègues lors fait à tous les
niveaux il a eu plus d'une centaine de
contacts
le temps non non non non le rayon voulu
minimiser sont pas réussi en est un
front commun
sur la table il y avait celui qui avait
été invité à mettre la table et s'il y
avait d'autres table pour discuter en
profondeur de sujets qui nous touchent
nous participation serait évidente avant
pendant et après mais d'après ce que je
sais il semble que la russie considère
qu' il ya eu une fin de non recevoir à
ces demandes étaient précises et
complètes et qu'elle ne souhaite pas
continuer la discussion
tant pis l'important c'est que nos télés
du monde libre du monde occidental pour
commenter
delà du rapport dans son antique de
l'union européenne
de l'union entre européens
la vision commune 7 kg appelle la
culture stratégie commune en est sortie
renforcée
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup merci pour
votre patience pour l'organisation pour
et puis ce cyclo note conférence de
presse bonne journée
[Musique]